can't believe we're finally leaving this  apartment and or office and or  government building and or hotel and or  superstore we're gonna miss this place  and even though i started out as a  bartender it's time for me to be the  president of the united states also  everyone's been married well the last  two seasons weren't very good well don't  want to miss our flight wait  let's take one last nostalgic look in  total silence  i'm gonna miss this place i'm gonna miss  this place  i'm gonna miss this place i'm gonna miss  this place i'm gonna miss this place i'm  gonna miss this place i'm gonna miss  this place great now let's break the  mood with a recurring joke that ties  into season one good thing kevin costner  doesn't have access to the nuclear codes  okay now just let me finish packing real  quick